all right so Spider-Man no way home the
more fun stuff version aka the extended
edition yeah that's just a lot of words
is now available on digital all you
Spidey fans have yet again another
excuse to binge this film with roughly
10 new scenes and a whopping 13 minutes
of footage now whether or not this
extended version is worth it is still up
for debate but the added post-credits
scene is the one bit we're going to be
focusing on because it does a way better
job at illustrating the somewhat
ambiguous Doctor Strange spell that was
cast at the end of the film so we're
gonna be diving into the original and
revised spells how this all actually
worked and how this potentially affects
Peter's future in a Spider-Man 4 and
Beyond now if you enjoyed this video
then web flip that like button as it
helps the channel and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns and Recaps
like this every day with that out of the
way a huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the video
so in this first part of the video I
want to recap the original and revised
spells Peter has Dr Strange cast for him
in the undercroft of the sanctum Peter
originally meets with Doctor Strange and
has him cast the spell stating
the entire world's about to forget the
Peter Parker Spider-Man
including me meaning the entire world
every single person will forget that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man which
honestly sounds like the best outcome no
one remembers who Spidey is hell it
could be Paul for all we know oi there
Governor swing and throw but I do
understand Peter's frustrations with him
not being able to share his secret with
his friends and family which drives to
not one not two but four interruptions
of Strange's spell resulting in it
Loosely following the parameters of
everyone that knew Peter Parker was
Spider-Man before should still know him
after now we know this obviously
resulted in other villains and Spiderman
who knew this secret to get sucked off I
mean sucked into the 616 Universe this
is why Nostalgia was ham-fisted into the
movie and it honestly it worked so so
well now if we fast forward to the end
of the film with Doctor Strange trying
to fix the multiversal fissures in the
sky preventing all of the other
characters from populating our main MCU
Universe Peter has strange changed the
spell too so cast a new spell but this
time make everyone forget who Peter
Parker is make everyone forget
me like the first spell every single
person on Earth will be affected but
instead of Simply forgetting that Peter
Parker was Spider-Man they will entirely
forget who Peter Parker is it's
essentially as though he never existed
he was never part of people's lives he
never saved the universe in Infinity war
and end game just poof almost like a
Thanos snap but solely for the Peter
Parker Persona I can't even imagine how
difficult it would be to get a driver's
license obtain a loan sign up for a
dating site like eHarmony I'm not I'm
getting off topic but you catch my drift
and this is what we all come to
understand with the final scenes of no
way home Happy doesn't know Peter MJ
doesn't remember him he is living by
himself and essentially leaning into the
Spider-Man Persona as his main life
while building everything back up
starting a new life with friends family
and loved ones I kind of assumed he was
a John Doe type character at the end no
paper trail through the what 18 years of
a his life so far however the
post-credits scene of the more fun stuff
version who who titled this of no way
home actually does a great job of
showing how this spell actually works
and I'm a little surprised that it was
left out of the theatrical version so
the scene first opens on high schoolers
at Midtown High looking up at a
television screen reminding them of
various things from graduation photo
pickup to cafeteria safety which is done
hilariously bad like of some sort of
late night infomercial but then things
shift over to Betty's corner with Betty
the Baddie Brandt as it's a bit of a
video yearbook looking back at the past
couple of years or rather the events of
homecoming and far from home there's
video from the decathlon prom Europe
trip along with explaining that some of
them disappeared for five years and then
reappeared thanks Grimace but one
interesting clip is the group posing on
their Europe trip the whole group is
posing but one person's face is
obstructed by some pigeons that are
flying through the frame and this is
Peter if we go back to far from home his
clothing matches this person's so
essentially Dr Strange's Spell straight
up Mike wazowskied him from any evidence
of his existence which is drastically
different from what we thought the spell
originally accomplished originally I
thought poof all traces of him were gone
but it appears that there's proof here
or there that some person existed with
them examples being that photo that I
just showed along with MJ still wearing
the necklace that Peter gave to her like
people remember a random person being
with them but do not know that it was
Peter which is honestly a strange way
about going with rings but I think if he
would have entirely been removed from
these situations or events the timeline
would have gone all wacky to backy and
caused much more of a fiasco than
essentially placing this faceless Sim to
live out these events while Peter does
have all of these memories sadly no one
else does now what does this mean for
Peter's future well it means he is
having to start over in the first three
films it was him coming into the
Spider-Man Alter Ego whereas here
without Aunt May happy The Avengers MJ
or Ned I think Spider-Man 4 will touch
on him having to build upon his Peter
Parker half it's a weird reset button in
a spidey sense that allows for the
character to meet entirely different
allies and villains splintering the
story in one of many different
directions pulling from the dozens of
comic story lines I could see Sony and
Marvel Studios sticking with the home
naming convention titling it Spider-Man
home again homesick or Spider-Man oh
[ __ ] here we go again and him actually
leaning into his Daily Bugle Origins
that we're used to this reset could also
bring in Gwen Stacy as a love interest
Felicia Hardy AKA black cat is a fly in
his web Harry Osborne or the MCU version
of Eddie Brock along with a whole Bevy
of spy Rogues gallery that we've seen in
previous installments or new ones that
have yet to get their live action
treatment hell maybe even a Sinister Six
movie oh no no no not this weird morbius
setup sinister six but with the Scorpion
man what whatever happened to this dude
like he was set up just Just For Nothing
of course this is all speculation in
theories but I do think that there's
going to be fractures in the spell that
doctor strange cast with this lingering
evidence of Peter Parker being present
in a couple of photos I can see MJ doing
some hardcore investigative journalism
because of the pictures and necklace she
has and solving who Spider-Man is once
again much like she did in far from home
they left the door open with those two
and it would be odd for them not to
somehow tie her and maybe Ned back into
the fold of it all another thing to
think about is the ripple effect of the
final spell that was cast everyone was
flowing into the main 616 Universe
because they knew Peter Parker was
Spider-Man
but with the final Spell essentially a
racing Peter Parker from the world does
that then jump into all of these
different universes and do the same
thing in the entire Multiverse no one
remembers Peter Parker because if so
that would be an already established way
to build upon a live-action MCU spite of
her story maybe not the most creative
way but it would allow for all of these
spider people to sympathize with one
another to help bring things back to
normal either way I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Peter Parker spell and
how you think it will play into the
future Spider-Man movies and even the
overall MCU in general and I'll let you
know we are currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
top gun Maverick on the 15th of November
and all you have to do to get a chance
of winning this is like this video make
sure to subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment Down Below on your
thoughts of Spider-Man then more fun
stuff version in this spell we picked
the comments at random at the end of the
month in the winner of the last month
are on screen right now so if that is
you message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch be sure to check out some of our
other cool videos whether it be our
house of dragon coverage or our
Halloween ends breakdown with that out
of the way thanks for the constant
support I've been Jared you've been you
this is the video and thanks for
sticking through
that rhymed and I I gotta get out of
here I'll see you in the next one take
care and peace